[Music]
Hi everyone. Um, thanks for taking the
time to be here today. Um, welcome to
this workshop where you will learn about
agents, multimodality and hopefully get
to build not hopefully you will build uh
a multimodal agent of your own from
scratch. Uh, who's first workshop of the
day? How many? Show of hands. Okay,
first workshop. How many people already
been in a workshop? Oh, wow. Like really
proactive, overachieving crowd. Great to
see that. All right. Um, with that,
here's a little bit about me. I am
Aurorva. Uh, I'll be your lead
instructor for today. I'm also joined
by, um, my awesome team here. We have
Richmond, he's waving at you. There's
Rafa back there. He's waving at you as
well. There's Tibo and we have Miko. Uh,
but yeah, here's a bit about me. Uh, I'm
Apurva. I'm currently an AI focused
developer advocate at MongoDB, which
means I spend a lot of my time building
uh workshops like this one for AI
developers like you uh to help them
build AI applications of their own. Uh
prior to this role, I spent about six
years working as uh a data scientist in
the cyber security space. And outside of
work, I like to read a lot. I try to
yoga pretty regularly or used to try to
till I busted my knee a while ago. Uh,
and I'm always on a mission to um visit
as many local coffee shops as I can in
whichever city I'm in.
So, this is what the next hour and 20
minutes is going to look like. Uh, we'll
be going over key concepts of AI agents,
discuss what multimodality is, and
finally we are going to put the two
together and build a multimodal AI agent
from scratch using good old Python. And
since this is a relatively short
workshop session, um this is what you
can expect. Uh we are going to focus on
getting concepts down. Um and we'll see
what we have time for. Based on my
practice sessions, uh I believe you get
about 55 minutes to an hour to actually
take your time to write code or just
like
get a really good understanding of how
uh multimodal agents work in code. So
just wanted to uh set that expectation
there
and with that let's get started. So
let's first answer two questions. What
are AI agents and why do we need them?
But even before I get into that uh how
many of you already have some experience
with AI agents?
Okay there some of you hopefully
there'll be something new for you uh at
this workshop and for those of you who
are new to the concept there's a lot of
stuff coming your way. So, uh, apologies
for that or not.
Okay, so here's my definition of an AI
agent. Um, I like to define an AI agent
as a system that uses a large language
model. I'll be referring to this as an
LLM uh to reason through a problem,
create a plan to solve uh the problem
and execute and iterate on the plan with
the help of a set of tools.
So in the past two years or so uh we
have seen three main paradigms for
interacting with LLMs. There's simple
prompting, rag and agents. So let's
briefly uh talk about each of these
because this will help us build an
intuition for uh when you want to use an
AI agent versus something else. So with
simple prompting, you're simply asking
uh the LLM questions and expecting the
LLM to rely on its pre-train or as we
call it parametric knowledge uh to
answer these questions. So this means
the LM cannot answer questions um if the
information required to answer them is
not present in its pre-trained
knowledge. It cannot really handle
complex queries and it cannot provide
personalized responses or even refine
its responses.
With Rag, uh, how many of you have built
a rag application? Okay, some of you.
So, you know, with Rag, you take this up
a notch. You augment the LM's knowledge
with information from external data
sources. And as you can imagine, this
solves some problems where you can now
be uh reasonably certain that the LM has
uh the information required to uh answer
user questions and also incorporate some
basic light personalization if it's
given access to the right sources of
information. But this still doesn't
equip the LLM with the ability to handle
uh complex uh multi-step tasks or to
self-refine its responses. But that's
okay because not all tasks might require
this capability.
And finally, uh 2025 is the year of
agents. So if you need uh if you have
complex multi-step tasks or need uh deep
personalization, any sort of adaptive
learning in your applications, then
you'd want to use AI agents. So with AI
agents, what we've done is given LM the
agency to determine the sequence of
steps required to uh complete a
particular task and they do this by
taking actions with the help of tools
that you provide them and reasoning
through the result results of these tool
executions and also its past
interactions
um to inform what to do next. And this
is what makes agents extremely flexible
and capable of handling a wide variety
of complex tasks. But the Yeah, sorry.
Will we share these the presentation?
Yes, it'll be shared. The you uh
recordings will be up on YouTube as
well. So yeah, uh the one thing to note
here though is that agents come with a
higher cost and latency. After all,
you're expecting LMS to do all the heavy
lifting of uh thinking through the
problem, coming up with a plan of
action, uh executing um the actions,
rectifying its responses. So, my word of
caution here is only use agents if you
need to. Don't complicate whatever it is
you're trying to build. But we are
building an AI agent today. So, for
today, let's just throw an agent at the
problem, a simple problem.
Okay. So to summarize, use agents for
complex tasks that don't have a
structured workflow or where the series
of steps required to solve the problem
is hard to predict or tasks that have a
high latency tolerance as I was just
mentioning or for tasks where it's
acceptable for uh your application or
system to return non-deterministic
outputs which means um the same uh
result is not guaranteed for the same
out inputs and this is true for any
application that uses LMS, but this
effect is especially amplified uh in
agentic workflows.
And finally, tasks that might benefit
from any sort of personalization or
adaptive behavior over a long period of
time. All of these are fair game for AI
agents.
Now, let's talk about the different
components of AI agents just to get a
better understanding of uh how these
systems work.
So an agent typically has four main
components. There's perception which is
how uh agents gather information about
their environment.
Planning and reasoning which helps um
the agent reason through a problem and
come up with a plan to solve it. Then
there's tools which are external
interfaces that help the agent act upon
and solve a problem.
And memory which helps agents learn from
past interactions. And if you are
passionate about memory, we have
Richmond who knows a lot about this
topic. So definitely uh catch him um
after or during the presentation. So all
of this sounds a bit like a human,
doesn't it? But that's the whole goal of
agents. The goal with uh LM based agents
is to give uh these systems the autonomy
to carry out complex tasks much like we
humans do. So it's not a surprise that
the components kind of resemble how we
um think through problems and go about
the world.
So let's dive a bit deeper into each of
these components.
Let's talk about perception first. So
perception as I said is the mechanism by
which agents gather information about
their environment. And this happens via
some form of inputs whether it's uh a
user like you interacting with the agent
or triggered by something else like an
email or a slack message. And text
inputs have been the most common form of
uh interacting with LMS and agents so
far. But over the past few months we've
seen um images, voice, video also being
part of this uh perception mechanism for
agents. And in today's workshop we'll be
working with two of these which is text
and images.
The next component we have is planning
and reasoning.
And shocker, the component that helps uh
agents plan and reason is LMS. So given
a user query, it's the LM's job to
determine how to go about uh solving the
problem. But they can't do all of this
on their own. They need some guidance.
And the way to provide guidance uh at
this point is to u prompt the LM.
And you can start simple by prompting
the LM to create a plan of action based
on its initial understanding of the
problem. And this is what we call
planning without feedback since the LM
doesn't really modify uh its initial
plan of action based on information
gathered from tool outcomes or its own
reasoning traces. And a common design
pattern for this kind of planning is
chain of thought.
And chain of thought is as simple as
prompting the LLM to think through a
problem step by step without um directly
jumping to uh giving the user an answer.
And you can do this in two ways. uh in a
zeros short manner where you literally
prompt the LM like tell it like let's
think step by step or you can do this in
a few short manner where you're
providing examples of how the LM should
go about thinking through a problem so
that the next time you give it another
problem it'll uh use your examples to
guide its reasoning process
then there's planning with feedback
where you can prompt the LM to uh adjust
and refine its uh initial plan based on
new information again obtained from uh
tool outcomes or based on its own uh
previous reasoning. And a common design
pattern that you will implement today is
uh react which is short for reasoning
and act. And what we do in this pattern
is you prompt the LM to generate
verbal reasoning uh traces and also uh
tell you the actions that it'll take to
solve the task. And then after each
action, we ask the LM to make an
observation based on uh the information
that it gathered from that tool
execution and think through that and
plan what to do next. And this continues
until the LM determines that I have the
final answer. And that's when it'll exit
that execution loop and provide the
answer to the user.
Then the next thing we have is tools.
And tools are essentially interfaces for
uh agents to interact with their
external world in order to uh achieve
their objectives. And these tools can
range from simple APIs such as I'm sure
you've seen uh examples of weather and
search APIs to uh vector stores to even
specialized machine learning models.
And tools for LMS are typically defined
as functions. And most recent LMS have
been trained to identify uh when a
function should be called and also the
arguments for a function call. But the
one thing to note is um the LM doesn't
actually execute the function. This is
something uh we will have to implement
in our code.
And in addition to actually defining the
function uh you typically also need to
provide uh the LLM a function or tool
schema. And this basically is just a
JSON file or with um MCP servers you
might have seen a different way of uh
defining uh tools but essentially you're
providing um the name of the tool to
call a description of what the tool does
and the parameters that the tool takes
and also their types and descriptions.
So for example, I have a weather tool
here and in my tool schema I'm saying uh
the name of the tool, the description
and saying uh the input that it takes as
a city, the type is string and uh the
description of that parameter.
And finally uh the last component is
memory.
This component is what allows AI agents
to store and recall past conversations
uh and enables them to learn from these
interactions. And memory, if you think
of human memory, it's a pretty nebulous
concept. There's so many different types
of memory. If you ask a psychologist,
they'll tell you all about that. But,
uh, I'm not a psychologist. So, uh, I
think of it in pretty primitive terms.
Uh, I think of it in as two broad
categories. Uh, one is short-term, which
deals with storing and retrieving
information from a single conversation.
And then there's long-term, which deals
with storing, updating, and retrieving
information. um had obtained over
multiple conversations had with the
agent over a longer period of time. And
this is really what um enables agents to
personalize their responses over a long
period of time. But in today's lab,
we'll implement short-term memory for
our multimodal agent.
And again, if you want to learn more
about this uh nebulous and extensive
topic, then here's a talk that I gave a
few months ago. Uh so I'll leave this
here for a few seconds but if you want
to talk to someone live then talk to me
Richmond Miko uh anyone from our team
moving on
okay so let's take an example and
understand how how all of these
components work together right so the
first thing that happens is a query
comes in to the agent here uh I'm asking
this agent what's the weather in San
Francisco today the agent forwards the
query a to an LM. So, think of agent uh
agents as a software application or
system with different components, one of
them being uh one or more LMS.
And the LM in this case has access to a
set of tools. In this case, it has
access to a weather and search API and
also its past interactions or memories.
So based on the tools it has access to,
in this case for this query, the LM
might uh decide that the weather API
would be the most suitable to get
information about this query. And it'll
also parse out the arguments for this
tool from the user query.
And like I mentioned, the your agent
also needs to have code to actually
execute the tools. So we have that in
our agent. It's going to make a call to
the weather API uh with the arguments
extracted by the LLM,
get a response back from the API,
forward that to the LM, and at this
point the LM has two options. It can
either decide that it needs to needs
more information and decide to call more
tools or it can be like I have the final
answer. Uh I'm going to generate that
now. So in this case, it has the
temperature in San Francisco. So it
might be like I know the answer. it
generates a natural language response
and that gets forwarded to uh the user.
So that's kind of the full flow of how
uh a tool calling simple tool calling
agent works.
The other thing we need to talk about
today which is the more interesting part
uh I believe is multimodality because we
are after all building a multimodal
agent.
So what is multimodality?
Multimodality in the context of machine
learning or AI is the ability of machine
learning models to process, understand
and at this point uh even generate
different types of uh data such as text,
images, audio, video etc. And like I
mentioned in today's lab, we'll be
working with two of these modalities
which is text and images.
So here's some real world examples of
data that contains a combination of uh
images and text just to give you some
inspiration for uh the kind of problems
and domains you can apply your learnings
from today too. So there's graphs,
tables and then there's these types of
data interle with text. So think of
research papers, financial reports, any
sort of organizational reporting uh
which typically has like some graphs,
analysis and text um all combined
together or healthcare documents. The
list is virtually endless. There's a lot
of uh a lot of real world um data looks
something like this.
So to make sense of this type of data,
we currently have two classes of
multimodal machine learning models. And
the first type of models we see are
multimodal embedding models. And the job
of these models is essentially to take
uh multiple types of data as input and
generate embeddings for them so that all
of these diverse data types can be
searched and retrieved together using
techniques like vector search, hybrid
search, graph-based retrieval, whatever
retrieval mechanism you want.
And the other class of models is
multimodal LMS which can um we deepsee
does that at this point claude uh open
AAI um like chat GPD has a voice mode.
So the job of these LLMs is to take all
of these different data types as input
and also generate uh outputs in these
different data formats.
Now, if you give a multimodal LLM tools
to search through multimodal data and
use its reasoning capabilities to make
sense of this information and to solve
uh complex problems, what you have at
your hands is a multimodal agent.
So, let's build that. Enough talk. Let's
actually talk about the agent that we
are going to build today.
So, we're going to start with something
simple. uh we're going to
um remove as many abstractions as
possible uh start with very simple
objectives uh and build an agent from
scratch so you get a really good
understanding of what it really takes to
uh build a multimodal agent in practice.
So our agent has two simple objectives.
The first one being answer questions
about a large corpus of documents and
then also given a chart or diagram help
the user uh make sense of it by
explaining and analyzing that uh figure.
I do this all the time when I'm reading
research papers. I'll just take a
screenshot pass it to Claude and we like
explain that equation especially with
all those like mathematical symbols and
whatnot. Sounds pretty reasonable, easy.
Not quite. There's a small catch and the
catch is we want to search over
documents with mixed modalities. So in
our case our corpus is going to be uh
documents that have text interle with
things like images and tables and that
complicates things because uh retrieving
the right information from mixed
modality documents is not a trivial
problem.
The challenge lies in actually preparing
the corpus of documents for search and
retrieval. So typically for textbased
documents, if you've built a rag
application, you chunk up those
documents, embed those chunks, and then
uh retrieve relevant chunks to pass as
context to an LLM. But you can't really
do this when you have images and tables
in your documents. And one way to do
this, there's so many tools out in the
market. There's like llama bars
unstructured that use uh vision
transformers or object recognition
models to first identify and extract the
different elements like they'll extract
text images tables separately then you
chunk the text as usual but you
summarize the images and tables instead
and then basically convert everything to
the text domain by uh creating
embeddings of the text chunks and
summaries using a text embedding model.
I know that's already a mouthful, but
you'll see how to simplify this process
using a new type of models. I'll just
get to that in just a little bit.
Another technique similar to the
previous one is that you still extract
the text and non-ext elements, you chunk
the text, but instead of summarizing the
images and tables, you would embed all
of these like the text chunks, images,
and tables using a multimodal embedding
model because uh it has the capacity to
um understand and embed all of these
different data types.
I already see some some of you losing me
because these uh pro data processing
pipelines are pretty complex and they h
they come with their own limitations
right they sound promising but they have
um mainly these two limitations. So the
first one is that they face the same
drawbacks uh that you see with chunking.
So to me the biggest problem with
chunking is uh the loss of context at
the chunk boundaries which is why
techniques like parent document
retrieval, metadata pre-filtering are
becoming popular where you add back
context that was lost during chunking at
either retrieval or generation time.
Also notice how complex these uh
processing pipelines were, right? you
need an object recognition model uh to
extract the elements. Another
potentially another LM call to um
actually summarize these elements in
addition to chunking and embedding which
is already one too many steps.
Another limitation with a lot of uh
multimodal embedding models lies in the
architecture of uh the models
themselves. So until recently the
architecture of most multimodal
embedding models at least for text and
images was based on OpenAI's clip model.
Um and what happens in this architecture
is text and images are um passed through
separate networks for generating the
embeddings of these data types.
And this results in something uh we call
a modality gap where irrelevant items of
the same modality end up uh close to
each other rather than uh relevant items
of different modalities. So in a clip
model for example, text vectors of
irrelevant text might appear close
together in vector space rather than uh
text and images corresponding to related
subjects. And that's a problem.
But this has changed with the advent of
a vision language model or VLM based u
architectures. So in this architecture
both moda modalities are vectorzed using
the same encoder and this ensures that
both text and visual features are
treated as part of a more unified
representation than as distinct
components.
So with these models, all you really
need is a screenshot of documents
containing
whether it's purely images, purely text
or an a combination of text, images,
tables, etc. And this is what uh because
of that unified architecture, it ensures
that the contextual relationships
between uh text and visual data is
preserved. So as you can imagine this
greatly simplifies the data processing
pipeline for multimodal data and also
ensures that you get uh better retrieval
quality uh because you're no longer
separating these text and images. So
basically given a document containing a
combination of text and images you
simply take a screenshot of it pass it
through a multimodal embedding model and
the embedding that you get from that
makes this data ready for retrieval.
Pretty straightforward process there.
So let's quickly look at some of the how
some of the key features of the agent
that we are going to build is work and
then we can go implement these in code.
So let's talk about the data preparation
pipeline for uh the corpus of documents
that our agent is going to use to answer
questions.
So like I mentioned the first thing we
are going to do is um for each document
in our corpus we are going to convert
that into a set of screenshots and in
our case each uh screenshot is going to
represent a page in the document.
We'll then store the screenshots
locally. But if you were to do this in
production, then you might want to store
them to some form of blob storage like
S3, uh Google Cloud Storage, whatever uh
your preferred cloud provider is.
And we'll also note the path to where
the image is stored
and then store this as metadata along
with the embeddings of the screenshots
generated using a multimodal embedding
model and store these into a vector
database.
So in our lab we'll use the latest
multimodal uh embedding model from YJI
and we'll use MongoDB as a vector
database because I work at MongoDB.
Uh not that so one thing to important
thing to note here that we are not
storing the raw screenshots. Yes. Yeah.
One quick question. Yeah.
So
you are retrieving the documents
into screenshots, several screenshots or
you're picking up the screenshots from
your document
and saving it to the so okay so say I
have a PDF containing multiple pages
each page in the PDF I'm going to take a
screenshot of it and each screenshot is
going to be saved separately in blob
storage and reference references will be
stored as metadata along with embeddings
in the vector database. And why do you
have to take the screenshot of each
page? Is it to save the space or uh so
like I showed you two methods before,
right? Like to be able to use the image
and table data for reasoning, you need
to uh be able to retrieve that document
that contains all of that together. And
the reason I'm taking a screenshot is to
preserve like the continuity between the
text elements and the image elements. So
all of them can be retrieved together as
context. But this is worse than chunk
chunks. What's that? I mean a screenshot
for each page. Who's the context of of
the whole I mean do but then with
chunking it's worse because you have
like a very uh usually you're keeping
like two paragraphs together or
something. So like slightly better. You
would always of course maybe want to
augment this method with metadata
pre-filtering other methods that you use
for traditional chunking but I still
think one page is better than two
paragraphs or a small paragraph of text.
Yeah. Do you want overlapping segments
here as well just like you do texting?
Uh yes. Yeah. So when you're So here
we'll take screenshots of like distinct
pages but uh if you want that continuity
you might want to like keep some overlap
as well. Yeah. How is this better than
giving it the full PDF at once? Uh
because LMS have like that lost in the
middle problem. So if you give it like
just because you have a large context
window doesn't mean you should flood it
because they still have the problem of
searching through like the full a large
document to find the right uh
information. So you're trying to
relation between these different states
maintain.
Yeah, I think as she was pointing out
either you'd have to like uh maybe
structure it a little differently to
have some overlap or store some
additional metadata to maintain that
continuity like page numbers or and
whenever you're retrieving a page you
could do something like retrieve the
previous two next two pages things like
that. Yeah. Any more questions?
Yeah. You talked about Voyage multimodal
3 like why why that one versus others?
uh any VLM based model really like the
whole point is to show you that
clip-based models have that I'm not
using a clip-based model because it has
a modality yeah modality gap but any VLM
based model is very good yeah so this
works for text and image yeah they're
more like medial right yeah like Yep
100% so this doesn't really deal with
that but essentially you could um extend
this concept step to different
modalities. It's just I typically don't
see like video or audio occurring with
text like I just chose this because uh
like images uh figures typically u occur
with text but so yeah screenshots might
not apply to other modalities. There are
different ways to handle it. Today we
are only focusing on images and text. Uh
okay two more questions. Okay,
uh I I guess this is different from the
larger language model, right? So it has
I guess smaller parameters than larger
than is a bit less I guess. Um it's just
it's still a large language and
language. For example, like we make an
embedding from the VLF text and then if
you make an embedding from the um uh
let's say um other 002 which is bigger
parameters then performance probably is
probably less. VLMs tend to get pretty
big too. So they are basically still
large models. They just can handle like
images and text, but they're still
pretty sizable models. Yeah. And I can
point you to some benchmarks that show
that they're still good at even purely
text or purely image data. And then a
combination of how to run the local
what's that? How to learn it run in the
local machine. I guess um like you'd
find a model that works with your
hardware specifications just like a an
LM, right? Like not all LMS can be run
on your machine. So it would be similar
to those. Yeah.
Um, no, there was one. Okay, one more.
Yeah. So, in this case, you're using
multiv, right? That your image and text
is strongly aligned. But what if you
have a modality that's really weakly
aligned time series, right? So, which
means your lat space they're not really
close. How do you handle those? Sorry,
can you say that again? If you have a
modality that's kind of not strongly
aligned with the rest of the modalities
like for example, time series, right?
embedded into the same dat
um so like time series data with text
like I'm I'm trying to understand like a
situation where you would have totally
dispar
time series too and that time series
data may not be really aligned with
and that means when you retrieve them
yeah they don't really go very well so
how do you handle those yeah I think
time series data typically ally you
don't even like use embeddings for it.
It's still it's just like you treat them
like any other features like you would
for traditional ML models. You
definitely want like a different uh
retrieval strategy for those. It would
be hard to put them in the same uh yeah
vector space as text and images. So you
might need to work with like different
retrieval methodologies. No problem.
Yeah. All right. Uh I'm going to move uh
forward here very like in a few minutes
we will hit the hands-on portion. So if
you have more questions, just um call
out to our team and we'll take more
questions then. Cool. All right. Um
okay. Okay. Let's quickly talk about the
workflow of our agent. We looked at a
random example before, but let's talk
about the agent you're bu you're going
to build. So query comes in, agent
forwards the query to a multimodel LM.
So note, we are going to use a
multimodel embedding model for
retrieval, but we also need a multimodel
LM. we are going to use I think Gemini
2.0 I know flash experimental some long
name uh but yeah basically we need that
LM because once we give it like um that
interle document with text and images we
need uh an LM that can make sense of
both these modalities so that's why I'm
using that LM it has uh just one tool
which is a vector search tool to uh
retrieve those multimodal documents and
also its past interactions and memory so
based on the query the LM can decide to
call the vector search tool. And if it
does that, it'll return the name of the
tool and the arguments um to use to call
the tool. Again, the agent has code to
actually call the tool. So, it calls the
vector search tool. And typically, if
you're working with textbased data, you
get the uh documents back directly from
uh vector search. But in this case, what
we are going to get back is references
to the screenshots. Remember, we didn't
store those in the vector database.
those are in our local or blob storage.
So then our agent needs to have that
additional step of using those image
references to actually get the
screenshots from blob storage and then
it's going to pass those images along
with the original user query and uh any
past conversational history to the
multimodal LLM. So each time an LLM call
is made, whether it's to determine what
tools to call or generate the final
answer, uh the images are also going to
be passed along with the query and
conversation history to the LLM.
Then it generates an answer and that
gets uh returned back to the user.
And finally, depending on the query, the
LM might also decide that it doesn't
need to call a tool. So for example, if
the user is simply asking like hey
summarize this image, it might not need
to uh call a tool. So in that case it'll
say I don't need to call tools. It'll
simply generate an answer and that gets
forwarded to the user.
Um and the final thing um let's talk
about the memory management mechanism
for our agent because this is important
for it to actually have uh coherent
multi-turn conversations with the user.
So like I mentioned before, we'll be
implementing short-term memory for the
agent. And the way this works is each
user query is associated with a session
ID just as some identifier to
distinguish between different
conversations. So given a user query, we
obtain its session or conversation ID
and we query a database consisting of
previous turns in the conversation to
get that uh chat history for that
session. And each time again in addition
to like the context we also pass in that
uh chat history just so the LM can use
that as additional context to determine
if it need even needs to call tools or
not.
And then when the LM generates a
response the other thing that happens is
we add uh this current response and the
current um query back to the database to
add on to uh the history for that
session. Now you can also log uh tool
calls, their outcomes, any um reasoning
traces from the LM, but at a minimum you
at least want to be logging uh the LM's
response and the user queries
themselves.
And finally, that is enough talking from
me. You I'll be quiet for the rest of uh
the workshop. We have about 45ish
minutes. So head over to that link uh to
access the hands-on lab. recommend
running that on your laptop. So instead
of Q that QR code, actually type in that
URL. This should take you to a GitHub
repo. Uh follow the instructions in the
readme to get set up for the lab. That
should take about 10 minutes. And then
you have two options. Um you can either
there are two notebooks in there. One is
called lab.ipb.
And if you actually want to if you're in
the mood to actually write code right
now, that's the notebook you'll be
using. You'll have you'll see reference
documentation in line in the notebook
indicated by that books emoji that tells
you use this documentation fill in your
code. You can do that if that sounds too
daunting. There's also a notebook called
solutions.ipb
that has all the code prefilled. So you
can just run through that notebook, read
the comments to get an understanding of
uh how the agent works. But whichever
option you use, I'm here, my team is
here. just call on us to uh if you have
any questions. And yeah, for anyone
actually filling in the code, you can
also refer to the solutions. Don't get
too frustrated if you get stuck. Uh we
don't want that. All right, so I'm
shutting up now. Um let's go ahead and
build that agent.
[Music]